hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy and i just wanted to remind you
that if
if you're in the position to do so to
think about making a donation to khan
academy we are a not-for-profit
organization and we can only exist
through donations from folks like
yourself and
now as we're approaching the one year
anniversary of
schools in the united states and
actually schools and much of the world
having to shut down physically
because of the pandemic it's even more
that we double down our efforts
obviously during the school closures
many many many folks
leaned even more on khan academy it was
the place where they went
to make sure that they kept pace with
their classes or if they weren't getting
distance learning that they were able to
get their learning
but now as we're starting to see the
light at the end of the tunnel i've
talked about this very publicly
we really have to view this as a
disaster recovery effort
because so many students most students
arguably
have accumulated all sorts of learning
loss over this past year
some students have fallen off the radar
completely and so as we go into
the end of this school year and actually
the next several years
we need to make sure that there's free
accessible resources
for students for parents and for
teachers and school districts
to make sure they can personalize to the
needs of students
and as you can imagine that's exactly
what khan academy is focused on
we had over 12 billion learning minutes
on khan academy
in 2020 and we expect that that will
only accelerate in the years ahead
that's 12 billion minutes
of learners around the world really
being able to dig into their gaps
make up for any unfinished learning and
then learn at grade level or beyond
so if you're in a position to do so the
social return on investment the social
benefit to cost ratio for khan academy
is off the charts and so hopefully it
will make you
make both your heart and your head feel
good about the impact that you will have
on
millions and millions of learners today
and billions of learners in the future